so I sold something on OfferUp I sold
like an Apple Watch on OfferUp it comes
he buys it cool for his girlfriend for
her birthday oh maybe like a five second
exchange she messages me at like 2 A.M
just like you're the most beautiful
woman I've ever seen I'm like I gave him
a deal too because he's like I'm buying
it for my girl he was gonna re-gift it
to you he was gonna make you his girl
you want to be so flattered
yeah if he did that as a joke yeah I
think that would be fine
when you got that message and you were
like oh what a disgusting guy you're
like block you're like still got it
was it a part of you that was like damn
I'm good like she gets a glance at
herself and the mirror and goes hell
yeah
I am that